let me tell you about another experiment
though that has to do with my sort of
background and growing up so I was in
high school and I grew up in Westchester
in a fine public school Scarsdale public
high school and I was doing biology sort
of on the side after school with this
wonderful teacher mrs. constant and
parenthetically I I found her using
internet a few years ago and I had the
opportunity to invite her to lunch at
the faculty club at the rockefeller sure
I mean she remembered me which was
pretty amazing because it was a long
time ago and she had moved to several
other schools since and it ended up i
think is a principle but we had we had
this really lovely lunch about two years
ago but I was doing experiments in the
prep room of the biology department and
I was doing a series of experiments on
frogs and tadpoles in growth hormone and
so I had different tadpoles and watch
glasses watch glasses are open vessels
that are in sort of like dishes this is
the best way to describe them and they
had different experimental conditions
and they were all labeled and I was very
methodically coming each day after
school because this was in addition to
my regular school work and noting the
changes in each condition based on the
dose of growth hormone and what I was
doing was was showing or demonstrating
how growth hormone induced
differentiation from tadpole to frog and
they were I don't remember the specifics
of the conditions now but what I do
vividly remember was somebody thought
they were going to be helpful to me and
this was after several weeks and they've
dumped all the watch glasses into a
bucket to wash them for me so all of my
experimental conditions into the bucket
so being the the 16 year old girl that I
was I was mrs. constant came in and
found me crying in the prep room so I
don't know what else to do I was just
you know beside myself and she said to
me she said you know you don't belong in
high school anymore she said we don't
have the resources to support your
interest and your education and you
should consider applying to college and
I said what do you mean instability you
can apply to college after three years
of high school if there's an academic
reason and you
have an academic reason so I I thought
about it and I went home and discussed
it with my parents particularly my
father and I really wanted to do it
partially for the academics and
partially I think I was anxious to get
out from home into college and what I
saw as my own life but really because I
I was very curious and I wanted to be in
a place where I could there were
laboratory resources that would support
that curiosity because it was clear to
me for me that the best way to explore
that curiosity was in the lab to work in
in something that I could touch and see
and feel and so I applied to college and
I was accepted to Wellesley with only
three years of high school for the
reasons that that I explained and I was
delighted and I was thrilled to be going
and you know Wellesley has an
association with MIT so I felt like I
had you know the world was my oyster but
when we went to meet with my high school
guidance counselor they didn't want me
to leave because I want a national merit
scholarship and there were various
things that were going to come to them
through me I think that and they just
didn't want people leaving so my father
you know talk to the guidance counselor
and guidance counselor said well you
know if she dropped if she leaves now
and we don't grant her the diploma and
she doesn't finish college she'll be a
high school dropout and my dad at that
point looked at the man he said we're
going to put our money on her and we
walked out and so I actually had to drop
out of high school so I was technically
a high school I guess I still am
technically a high school dropout and
for many years I got GED you know high
school equivalency stuff to my house so
I'm kind of proud of that and on my CV I
have that I attended high school for
three years but I was actually never
awarded I school diploma I did however
get my college diploma and my medical
school degree as well so so I feel
pretty good about that but I went off to
I went off to Wellesley for that reason
you